we all
must advocate for women
the rights of women and girls
to use their full talents
to contribute economically politically
and socially
and pursue their dreams free of violence
and intimidation
from central america to the middle east
to africa to afghanistan
wherever it appears in the world
we almost call out and condemn
the targeting and oppression of racial
ethnic and religious minorities
when it occurs in whether it occurs in
xinjiang
or northern ethiopia or anywhere in the
world
we all must defend the rights of lgbtqi
individuals so they can live and love
openly without fear
whether it's chechnya
or cameroon or anywhere
as we steer steer our nations toward
this inflection point
and work to meet today's fast-moving
cross-cutting challenges let me be clear
i am not agnostic
about the future we want for the world
the future will belong to those who
embrace human dignity
not trample it
the future will belong to those who
unleash the potential of their people
not those who stifle it
the future will belong to those who give
their people the ability to breathe free
not those who seek to suffocate their
people with an iron hand
authoritarianism
the authoritarianism of the world
may seek to proclaim the end of the age
of democracy
but they're wrong
the truth is
the democratic world is everywhere
it lives in the anti-corruption
activists the human rights defenders the
journalists
the peace protesters on the front lines
of this struggle in belarus burma syria
cuba venezuela and everywhere in between
it lives in the brave women of sudan who
withstood violence and oppression
to push a genocidal dictator from power
and will keep working every day to
defend their democratic progress
it lives in the proud of the moldovans
who helped deliver a landslide victory
for the forces of democracy
with a mandate
to fight graft
to build a more inclusive economy it
lives
in the young people of zambia who
harness the power of their vote for the
first time
turning out on record numbers to
denounce corruption
and chart a new path for their country
and while no democracy is perfect
including the united states
we'll continue to struggle to live up to
the highest ideals to heal our divisions
and we face down violence and
insurrection
democracy remains the best tool we have
to unleash our full human potential